meantime lines at cashman center were
longer than usual as our state recently
expanded its vaccine eligibility
madison kimbrough spoke to some people
in line today
yes thousands of people took advantage
this saturday and waited in line to get
their first dose vaccination
shot this comes after the news on
thursday that workers in the restaurant
hospitality and casino sectors were
eligible to get their vaccines
this is major news for vegas since the
majority of our economy
is based off of the food and casino
industry according to stats we got from
the clark county fire department
just under 6 400 people were vaccinated
today
that is the most in one day for nevada
with a moderna and pfizer vaccine being
available
at this location for today all the long
lines were a bit
overwhelming for some the majority got
in and out in a timely manner
of course we had to deal with a little
longer line but it's still the purpose
for why we even were in that line
to get the vaccination to try to stay
away from the national cove
many people who weren't eligible yet
also decided to come out and wait
standby
with the hopes of getting in earlier
this week president biden announced that
he is directing all states
tribes and territories to make all
american adults eligible for the covet
19 vaccine
by may first and in our state of nevada
they are working to make appointments
available at pharmacies
too here at the cashman center they
stopped taking appointments at four
o'clock today
and reminder that they are closed on
sundays and mondays
reporting in las vegas madison kimbrough
8 news now